[Music]
you're allowed to freestyle if you want
to take it if you want to uh are you
feeling it yet but I keep playing it
though yeah you guys is a rod simple
beat rod Simba is one of the amazing
listeners of this podcast
he's also the music producer and over
the years he's just sent us music this
is what we [ __ ] do this is hockey this
is uh why I'm a Pete Rock Ellijay you
know what I've never played this song
for Westbrook and Griff didn't hear it
Nick can you play Warren sharps intro
music please this is the the show we do
it listen to this beat drum
give me some J Dilla man it's a gambling
podcast so you get the money flips rod
Simon the regulator's it'll [ __ ] around
this down once gone down ones dropping
they just go in the booth and they make
some music and they go left ko do you
like this think oh [ __ ] is Italy there's
a lot the other voice that we have with
Westbrook today is truly a guy that like
I grew up with and he's the [ __ ] man
Robert Griffith safety three teams I
always knew you as the Vikings but you
know you're a good player when other
teams are like we're gonna need you to
come in and provide some structure
Browns Cardinals as well to four we have
mutual friends in common and I said come
on we're not gonna talk that much
football we're gonna have a good [ __ ]
time and you said yes and I appreciate
um you know it's good to be here
we had a great talk last night a lot of
energy little crowd royal yeah performed
John T Austin holy crap man he's got a
new album out too
slamming so you know how like you can
meet people from Atlanta like this guy
has seven Grammys and you're like wait
who are you and you're like you know
your favorite Mariah Carey song he wrote
he wrote it that's his nephew yeah and
like think about Atlanta cause like with
Atlanta there's so many people riding
around and nice cars you're like what
who are you what do you do ya know they
make all the beats of music that we
listen to
Griffith walked in the studio when the
first thing he said was Reese's
and yes almost started arguing he does
not like chocolate and peanut butter huh
it's not they don't go together in my
opinion and most most sane Americans
opinion chocolate and peanut butter do
not go together however who said
chocolate and peanut butter don't go
together the same Americans the people
with with since brains
so just because I like data right
Reese's Cups is number one that got
handed out I misjudged Americans some
people are just 0.9% of the country is
disappointing man chocolate and peanut
butter do you really like them together
really would you have rather have them
Jesus in heaven and they put this dumb
box behind tears that all the time just
you know Reese's just to piss me off
yeah there's the box everybody
millennial so me and Bert our producer
came out with a list of food
combinations and it's so funny that we
started here because I'd like to know on
a scale of hate it's okay or love it
there is no in between I don't need a
number and and because I can tell that
Grif is sensible like me we're gonna
react to a taste buds okay chocolate and
mint never hate it Wow
chocolate chocolate is good with a lot
of stuff not men never had a peppermint
pattie I think I have in there doesn't
like chocolate chocolate I love
chocolate but they listen I mean it's
okay it's not peanut butter in Chakri I
like these things separate I like mint
and I like chocolate out putting them
together is foolish tomato soup and
grilled cheese tomato soup should never
be eaten period I'm not a big tomato
soup guy but well I can see they go
together I'm gonna what about what about
dipping french fries into a chocolate
shake
what like into well nobody's there's
nobody that does that I do it no no way
I would like to be a hell no on that one
too hot feelings doesn't go to fold repo
in America
you're wrong you'd go to Wendy's yeah
you get a frosty and you dip a fry in
their legendary terrible buffalo wing
and blue cheese blue cheese does not go
away
cheese is a racial we like you're like
ranch man we just like just like I think
the greatest thing that people of color
do is when they see each other say just
trying to be like you why people don't
do that white people be like are you
okay bagels with cream cheese and lox
bagels only have butter on them not
cream cheese you know in New York dude
you have so many people in New York they
take the bagels and they just put cream
Chiana schmear it's just too much way
too much I'm begging okay with the cream
cheese but the LOX
I don't know what is locks it is that
LOX is a salted fish now it's like sand
it anymore it's a it's a Jewish who's
doing that you're doing a Jewish thing
yes but I would say I had a big long
with her own soda fish yeah I can filter
fish yeah oh you know do you know do you
know what can filter fish have a lot of
Jewish stuff by the way really really
yeah I just had my first Seder the last
year yeah that's a whole nother Oprah
man this weekend I felt good about it
right um
water with lemon yeah I'll do it it's
not man got you pancakes and syrup yes
yes with butter first no of course you
start with the butter um and I'll do
I'll do one do you like chips and salsa
I love chips and salsa one of my
favorite snacks the nacho is one of my
favorite your guacamole he said I did
not know they're not so angular awesome
nachos
Oh Adam you owe me a money he owes me a
lot of monies I do not owe you any of
the monies no walk walk is a no-go for
me
what detector - creepy Mexican man I
grew up in San Diego
yeah it's chips and guacamole salsa
other stuff it's cream I don't like the
creamy - I don't but you're chewing your
you're biting into it is no good so good
dude I've ever known yeah no he doesn't
like peanut butter and chocolate yeah he
doesn't dip French fries no Chuck I'm a
discipline man principled in discipline
I like my food and I don't think we're
enjoying life well enough I'm not living
life yeah there's better kind of like
I'm missing and missing out on some
stuff I think what we're gonna do next
week I feel good do some blindfold taste
test it's over dad we're not gonna
that's the last thing we would not be
doing Griff I was I was looking on this
incredible database called Wikipedia you
were teammates with Marshall Faulk
in college oh yes so when you so
Westbrook was this dude in college where
he ran everything himself he was like
the all-time yards leader mm-hmm when
you're on one side of the ball and
Marshall Fox on the other side of the
ball is your college experience like
let's high-five each other as we switch
to just kick these teams asses uh yeah I
love Marshall Marshall was that guy man
so I did a little bit back story I
hosted him when he came on his visit of
course yeah you know I'm a San Diego
yeah I'm 100% I got every recruit that
ever came on a visit was by the way and
so Marshall came and he came in on the
Saturday and he was you know Marshall
went to an all-black high school so when
he came to San Diego was just big just
like yeah he got dropped on Mars man and
so I went to go hang out with all my
multicultural friends and he was just
amazed that we were all interacting that
way you know it was just it was it was a
mind blow for him anyway that was
Saturday Sunday my mom my mom's from
Mississippi she made him some southern
food yeah yeah he fell asleep on the
couch in my mom's house and he woke up I
was like I'm coming
Wow yes he got the itis and said I'm Tom
come just like that and you know like
when you recruit you like hit up the
coach while he's taken that mean like we
got him got him
no no mames fool the Guardians knocked
about you know no but it was a big thing
for us to get him you know they put how
good was he at college because we all
see the NFL step night and I saw a lot
of this high school in in College film
but it may he was special special in the
UH I don't know about all the stats but
I know my senior year Marshall we played
SC we tied them he ran for $2.99 then we
went to BYU I think he ran for 300 then
we had UCLA and I think he ran for two
something yeah like seven eight hundred
yards in three games man that's AA and
we knew right away when he I think the
first play I remember him catching a
screen being surrounded by you know a
lot of three or four guys him catching
it with one hand
shaky-shaky spin move ninety know you
know a lot of colleges like Miami he had
offers everywhere they sent him to play
defense oh so he knew that he was gonna
we had a senior running back TC get a
chance to play yeah those are always the
stories that you look back and you're
like you wanted him to play that right
everyone Randall Cobb went to Kentucky
he's from Tennessee and the reason was
Tennessee was like you're gonna play
running back in Kentucky will let you
play quarterback and they just get the
kid in the door huh wait so you were an
all-pro in 2007 Westbrook you were an
all-pro 98 99 how different is it to an
NFL player of an all-pro versa Pro Bowl
like is that does it mean a lot more to
you guys to it means a lot more to me
most definitely it does because all-pro
is there's one all protein so it's
basically one from every position it's
kind of the best of its we're because
here's the other thing you could make an
all protein without being the first team
Pro Bowler which is kind of crying
there's a lot it happens all the time
but it's the best of the best extra
position which is you know much more
significant at that time yeah I feel the
same way so Pro Bowls more you know you
could be popular around a good defense
and kid
a lot of teams like I know a lot of
people have but the all-pro is one team
so if your first-team all-pro
you are the guy when you become an
all-pro right what is the offseason
after becoming an all-pro like because
now everyone's like you're a you're a
top to safety in the NFL right
you're a top two running back how do you
keep that motivation kind of going when
you get crowned in a way it was more
motivation for me I mean it was just
more validation that I know I was doing
the right things I'm busting tail on the
field yeah but more importantly that the
coaches saw it you know the other teams
had to you know I always ask guys and I
don't know if you've done this before
but doing when I played it was almost
like do they have my jersey on at
practice mm if they got you know that is
specifically me forget the dances right
forget the popularity do they have my
damn Jersey on on the other side yeah at
practice and if they do then you're the
guy you walk up and they go 24 like they
feel the need to point you out I would
call former teammates Randall Cunningham
guys like that be like hey Griff they
got your Jersey on me they worried about
yeah well you gotta call the strength
you got to do something wrong man I'm
I'm a part of this game and that yeah
that means a lot to me it's right in the
mouth that's what you used to hit people
in the mouth I try my best
yeah you are you are the Vikings for a
long time do you still feel yourself
rooting for the Vikings is that most
definitely yeah you know they gave me my
start you know I was undrafted you know
a rest in peace dinner screen and but
definitely I played eight years there
Cleveland was kind of like a blur we
weren't that good the last two years and
then Arizona was just on my way out you
were in Minnesota with Robert Griffin -
right no I'm very fit
no talking Smith I love that career
nice aims fast you know much faster than
a lot of people thought he made him loud
people miss true trying to get plants
one of the great what-ifs because it was
it was Chris Carter and Randy and
Randall and it was like clicking and
then you had you had Robert yeah and it
was like this is the new the new Dallas
Cowboys trio it was a Quattro and then
he wore screens to the crib man that's
15 in 198 had it right I want to talk
yeah we lost that game tempo baby my
force right yeah yeah Gary Brooks got a
pick at the end that was such an
underrated rivalry was Vikings bucks
that was big time oh man oh man
Dennis Green yeah like do you have a
story that kind of shows why he's so
beloved because like people talk about
him now and they just shake their head
they go great man like was there as a
coach was there a story that you're like
that's Danny Green uh you know he was a
true embodiment of what's going on at
home is more important than what's going
on in his so valuable
yeah and it's like I gotta get a guy to
play hard for me so I got to make sure
he's good off the field I was kind of
like the underlying factor that handled
all of his decisions but Denny was just
you know he was evolved he was a player
he wasn't you know all-conference
running back in Iowa right in the 70s
right so and then he was around all
these guys so people don't realize and I
go through a little bit of ecology for
Denny he was uh you know this is after
his time at Stanford he had three stints
at Stanford running backs coach
offensive coordinator then head coach
right but when he in between that he was
Jerry Rice's rookie wide receiver coach
I mean Jerry is Jerry because he got
that nice real blueprint from Denny yes
I have never heard that mentioned before
yeah he was when Jerry talks about his
process you hear about the hills you
hear about catching bread oh look at the
history well no I'm definitely Green as
his rookie wide receiver cuz he set the
tone
Wow and it's just stuff like that you
wouldn't know and then and then he comes
to coach you and you're like that's
right and then his tree I think his tree
is tremendous I have a lot of people on
to talk about it there's a lot of rings
under that tree Tony Dungy Brian Billick
mm-hmm
Jack Del Rio sure is my middle
linebacker when I got to the Vikings you
know just guys like that man Chris
Dolman yeah we start talking about the
legends of the game yeah you know there
was a lot of them that came to Minnesota
do you think this Vikings team can make
a run yes I know it's all on cousin
shoulders that's that's that's the
problem that that's what I'm saying
don't get me wrong do later cuz I like
it when he's a great guy but great guys
don't win Super Bowls you have to make
that throw it don't third and eight in
the playoffs they do have a great team
though I think their defense is gonna
play a lot better what's his record in
like prime tambien like the big games he
does not the biggest games he doesn't
perform yeah that's like that's what I
was thinking I was watching the game
Sunday mmm I'm like here's Minnesota
they're hanging around we can put a lot
on the missed extra point which put them
in that weird situation but when they
needed a drive they punted it twice
yeah and running backs can get bottled
up in the playoffs you know like if I
only have to worry about feeling and
digs I think that Smith kid yes and
could turn into something I will he do
well I think they have enough pieces so
now you have two tight ends they can
actually get open and run yet Smith is
incredible and you look great right
runner you run some 12 yeah right
well we do that a lot - bye - so now you
can't double and if you do double once
somebody's open I can't double everybody
right so I would and then you have the
ability to max protect - man Ralph yes
you can run the ball I mean I just think
it's the best their best personnel group
they say should go out on the field was
just gonna come down and Dalvin cook is
a guy
Darwyn cookies do you oh yeah you know I
Xplosive fast yeah he could do it all I
think they have enough the offensive
line
yeah can be a little they you know
little spotty at times they got play a
lot better down and stretch the win it
cuz I look at that's why I was saying
that the Vikings of the Seahawks remind
me of them of each other were they they
each have flaws but the difference is
Russell can make up for all the flunk
and when you have a Russell or DeSean or
a Lamar it can mask a lot of problems
everybody
I picked the Ravens to win the AFC
preseason he made fun of me for a few
weeks nobody knew he was gonna play like
this thank you nobody knew that it's
kind of hard to know that he's gonna
play so it's definitely revisionist
history but I will say that when you
watch the off season go and you listen
to these coaches they were talking about
Lamar in like they discovered gold like
every quote from Harbaugh in the
offseason was we were not expecting him
to do this we were not expecting to
throw it like this former players and
you know of all the former players the
Ravens are probably the hardest critics
cuz it's a lot of you guys mmm like
Miami guns and those guys never want to
give credit to the new guns and they
were like this the market looks
different I don't think we knew that
they were gonna have such a great plan
that they were gonna keep three or four
tight ends and two or three running
backs and create this beautiful system
that like she shifts
that's what spin I mean Ingram is not
done do not trip that dude is a hard
tackle man hold onto the football but
yeah now he runs like a man though who
runs like a man alright so you're here
on a Wednesday which means we're going
to the cup uh-oh
what's the cup the cup is weird random
questions that are typically not
football related but you need to say
into a weird voice so I'm gonna let you
reach in and I want you to do your best
as newscaster voice as you read it
my newscast of all yes pretend you're
doing
[Music]
oh nice all right you have to do it out
loud though I don't know this and this
is a what newscasters Kaster hmm see if
I can get a Anderson Cooper here nice
how many bleacher report employees would
it take to keep Lamar Jackson and a full
offensive line from picking up ten plus
yards perfect and we were just talking
about Lamar so is completely random
all right so how many just random tech
people in this office would you need to
put on the field to stop Lamar from
picking up ten yards with the full
offensive line
whoa from this office yes thirty people
I think it's the guys downstairs the
girls now say they do a great job of
what they do but it ain't they don't
seem like they're cool not was a geeky
but they're cool so smart people they're
great people they do a great job on the
computer yes but get on that football
field and tackle somebody tackling
someone that nobody in the NFL can tell
of this Lamar Jackson with no offensive
line probably probably say probably ten
eleven on I think that you guys are nuts
I think I 70 no way Lamar Jackson would
make ten employees in this company fall
on their face well no I'll tell you why
the athletes here we're question when I
saw the little deal you guys did of
catching the punt yeah I'm not every
person here but yeah you look terrible
you look terrible trying to capture the
punts is not thank you I caught the
beauty you can do that without looking
unathletic
I wasn't there people say that I'm a
surprising athlete they put a caption on
there that says in Adam left coup then
who never has played organized football
that's true and it looked like that but
I understand it never have never never
put on a helmet and
never had a jersey on man yeah because
you know I could tight in that's why
oh I'm bill I'm like here's a thing
here's the thing that's troubling you
time religion hands I've really good
hands I'm really good in the huddle yeah
we're going to new threw the ball 56
miles an hour I caught it I'm good hands
accidentally shut the [ __ ] actor was
accidentally catch what voice should
Brian Westbrook have to do for this fun
Robert Graham we need a sultry bubbly
love sponge type of DJ voice DJ voice
[Laughter]
Bobby West on the mic 80w jjz yeah if
you want my number call me a 3/4 know if
someone handed you a sealed envelope and
inside was a date of your death would
you bother to open it or not mmm so
you're handed a sealed envelope that's a
serious tell you the day you die would
you o do that come from that's a serious
one there
I know take a second well the first one
you got to figure out do you want to
know where you die because if you do
it's my way do you wanna you want to be
able to say okay I need to get a lot in
in this time 20 years from this date I'm
gonna die I got 20 years to rock out but
my thing is is that why don't you think
like that anyway great well we should
wait philosophical we shouldnt I well
here's the thing because we always
planned for tomorrow that's why let's
let's think about how learning the date
of your death impacts the way you live
mm-hmm I have said many times it's this
phrase amor fati which is live as though
you're gonna die like no like no like
love your death yeah that way you can
live life more but let's say you find
out you're gonna die in 30 years
yeah dude is it does it make you Coast's
because you know you have time what if
you find out you're gonna die in 30 days
I think those 30 years ago by faster if
you knew faster
if I knew I was gonna die in 30 days
there's gonna be a hell of a 30 days oh
yeah pardon me I'd only want to open it
if I was gonna find out that I was gonna
die very soon yeah like if I found out
like a night in 40 years like okay let's
say it says you're gonna die on April
15th every April 15th now you're like
I'm gonna die 29 more 29 something they
were like yeah I got 30 summers left
okay I got that say that's real comedian
yeah Deon Cole Bianco you started
thinking that way though yeah 29 more of
these what now here's the deal I would
know it now don't open it
are you now living your life kind of
being like I don't know what I'm gonna
die but then again we don't know we do
that now we do that now all right you
see more philosophical about this how
would you approach it I think I would
open it man you're hoping for it far
away w-would you don't want is open I
mean whatever it is what if it's the
truth right God puts the envelope right
you know what's weird though it's I
would open want say what time what do
you mean well I so let's say it says
you're gonna die in a certain date and
then that date comes and you wake up oh
you just don't know like your what year
you more or you don't know how you just
know that that's your death day bro you
don't know what year yeah you know a
year but like let's say today it arrives
okay you wake up and you look at like
somebody you go I'm gonna die today but
you don't know how you don't know when
that's wild deep conversation yeah what
voice should I do
well change it up I got a couple of them
here from couple viewers yeah okay they
have one Ron Burgundy have we done him
yet oh he just did newscaster Kenny
Powers I don't really do understand him
though what do you mean you don't do and
then I'll imitate you doing Kenny Powers
do Ricky Bobby you know Ricky Bobby not
first you're last okay let's go okay all
right guys if you're our coach and your
team was losing at halftime let me try
to get you're a coach
losing a half times you don't finish
first or last but no one on your team
has ever seen any movies
what is this accent what is this country
so your coach you're losing at halftime
and no one on your team has ever seen a
movie in their life what sports movie
speech are you stealing to inspire your
team ooh
see you could take any speech from any
movie and they'll think it's coming from
you he's in there laughs the memory of
Titans okay okay so eaten what's another
one so the first one that I went to was
output to your uncle Oh Jamie Foxx it
was any given Sunday I was thinking of
the hockey one miracle where he's like
it's not the name on the front but the
name on the back no nothing on the
background the name on the front yeah
remember Dan still had to have a good
line I think this might be the worst
assemblance of people to quote movies
yeah we ever know I'm not good yeah how
are we supposed to remember anything
nothing we remain under those things
that's the way it is that was some truth
right there yeah it's real truth have
you guys ever met each other in a hole
did you ever hit like was there we
played again yeah we played in each
other yeah you mentioned it earlier we
don't you talked about the other team
worried about that guy that's that guy
you say okay make sure as a running back
you're always okay where's the safety
and I'm not worried about the offensive
line the defensive line because they're
gonna get blocked and they're also cause
I think westbrook's like I'm gonna get
past the first - yeah I'm getting past
those yeah but they got to read the
Safety's right I need to know what to
say these at and how fast he's coming
because that's the guy that could hurt
you that's the shots that you don't see
and you like hole up and that's when
things get a little blurry he and a
colleague I was ronnie Lott you're
number one I had a couple other guys too
whoo-hoo-hoo so a lot of people don't
talk about like Martin Bayliss and you
know Dennis Smith
like that man Dennis Smith from from
Denver was a good play yeah sure
is it weird as as we all get older that
we slowly forget people from the
generations before is that weird for you
guys to sleep now because like I'm sure
you played on some teams with guys where
you're like oh people will never forget
you and then you name drop somebody and
it's like who
yeah that's wild yeah cuz you know a lot
of stuffs not memorialized right so now
we have all of the opportunity to you
know record yes post and whatnot so a
lot of guys are falling in between the
cracks like Dennis Smith nobody talks
about him they talk about Atwater still
a little bit but these guys weren't you
know incredible safeties I think about
like Rodney Harrison
alright so Rodney got known as a dirty
player a little bit more than I he was a
little bit on the edge I guess for lack
of better words but Ronnie was a baller
I also got a with my safeties being
dirty I mean you want your safeties
you want your safety to be respected so
that's what I was out there for every
time I mean it
that's why I say if you were wearing my
Jersey then I knew it I was supposed to
be doing I was doing him right right is
if you want you well if the old football
league was that guy will hit you hmm and
you know that wins games how many games
we won Dawkins mother a long time is the
big part of it when I came out of
college you know I didn't get drafted so
I only had three teams to work me out
since I know the word the Giants
Cincinnati and Oakland that's it not
even the Vikings
no no Vikings and it wasn't it so I went
to can't you guys you don't know the
story
tell me Oh so I played this little he
tweaked it up so man I played this I
played Rover in college and what was
really hurting me in college to get
drafted was really a godsend because
that's what its safety did in the NFL so
I played Rover saw was the weak side
linebacker when we played two back teams
but then I had to go cover as a third
nickel
when we went one back teams and we
played in the WAC everybody was one back
or you know if they went to two backs I
had to fit the run that's like the most
I got a ball position yeah so I got I
was a Swiss Army knife so I got an
opportunity to learn a lot of football
learn how to fit know how to front front
was blocking and all that stuff so but I
was a hundred eighty eight pounds you
know 190 and I think I won 90 when I got
out of college so too small to play
linebacker they didn't really see me
play corner like not know nickel right
for real and then as a safety they were
like eyes too slow that uh just kind of
neutral right for lack of better word
right and then I ran four or five one
coming out of college I wasn't like
blazing right so I went to Canada I
don't know I get deep in it but in in
the 1993 there was five Kim Canadian
teams there were in the US Sacramento
Vegas Baltimore there was a couple other
teams and I went to the Sacramento team
no money in my pocket I actually stayed
with her buddy of mine that just got a
job up there in Sacramento and stayed on
his couch for a month learned all the
Canadian plays about to go into my first
game and they were like we actually
traded you this morning so I'm up there
learning place for a month yeah I bought
me some new Newman gloves this is old
school I'm walking stadium with Newman
gloves that I just bought and a coach
calls me and he says hey man we traded
you unfortunately you can't even you
know be on the sideline you gotta watch
the game in the stands and I'm like you
know my people they're cold-blooded so
anyway I went back got back in the
school bag my professors got all seized
that semester but what I did do and it
changed my life my career I know I got
off oh yeah is I got on the track with
Ron Sheffield who is the Sprint well
he's a track coach track coordinator at
UC Davis now
and world we're now in sprint coach and
I started working with him five days a
week working out with Olympians in San
Diego State and I did that all the way
into April and then that's when I got a
call from Gary's owner who just got the
job as a special teams coordinator for
the Vikings and I was in great shape I
was running for fours and I ran a few
four threes people keep laughing I say
that but I was rolling man you know part
of it was just me learning how to run
you know just learn how to run like
track you know yeah different track he's
a track guy right so well I'm just
saying what what is like a one simple
thing that people don't realize that
track people do to make them faster than
people that don't know how to run like
what's like a simple thing well when
you're running track everything's
forward so there's no side movement
there's none of that everything is tight
everything is tight straight all your
energy is going to turn over as well
pick your feet up putting them down
right on the ground and rigging it back
yes that's the other thing
claw on the ground you're coming back to
the ground with your foot rolling
already it's kind of like when you're
learning how to play golf and someone's
like you actually have to swing down
right gotcha it doesn't make sense okay
so that entire e kill you're like oh man
there's no ground time right so football
players we want to be on the ground we
want to be able to cut track it's no I
want to not be on the ground
I want to tap it in and go right so what
do I learn how to run and yeah got that
work out with the Vikings and you know
we another story and a coach looks at
the stopwatch shows it to somebody like
holy Sh and you know I remember so I
missed a whole year football right and
then so the next year I come out and I'm
working out with the same or the new
group of seniors sure and that's when
Sean Payton who was a ga at our school I
don't know if you know that but he was a
GA when I was in Colorado head coach of
the say yes
Sean Payton yes
yes he was a graduate assistant at San
Diego State when I was there that's
really cool yeah so he was he you know
he was timing and he always says man
CRIF he stole first base because I was
out there a year later and so anyway
that's that's how I got on the what is
like a chance it's like this he's Sean
Payton as long as NFL it's my boy
deserves he's smart dude always been in
hangs in the NFL - yeah most definitely
almost down I want to know about Randy
what was Randy like those first couple
years in Minnesota I mean obviously he
was a little raw but when you saw that
type of talent cuz we the leak hadn't
seen a big guy that can run that type of
fast since yeah ever really yeah but you
know big guy that can actually get low
and change the records and go - so
that's the thing people are they go home
he's big he's fast no but Randy used to
be able to cut and change directions
like a little guy but and I was telling
you last night laughs is that a when I
saw Randy I was like man this guy's
gonna get broke up man yeah I was like
just do this six-four don't weigh
nothing I don't see no muscles like I
mean you know long muscle right but I
don't see nothing he looks like he's
playing basket on protection right first
day of one-on-ones I knew that he was
the guy oh man I went over Chris I
tapped Chris I was like what he was like
yes yeah you know Chris yes like and so
it was like dead-set immediately oh man
we star we we knew right away he was
gonna take the top off and Chris was
gonna do his work and I I really believe
and I know Chris was a hip right he
should acknowledge this is that Randy
actually helped him of course
propel that I'm sure yeah but wait a
minute
when you have a rookie that comes in
that's so great but it's so in the
nature of sports to kind of give the
rookie a little bit of a hard time how
do you balance between being like you're
[ __ ] incredible and you're still a
rookie like how do you balance didn't
really go through a little in any of the
rookies because he was on the edge -
don't like it was do score 17 touchdowns
looky here man cuz I met more training
camp stuff yes yeah well
he did I will say he did sing I'm kind
of remember what he's saying so you know
typical rookie stuff yeah and on your
chair give me a you know don't get me no
rap song send me some more and be ready
fight song something and that's when
Randy had that severe West Virginia
accent yes like the accent was coming
here to go teeth in there too oh yeah
yeah yeah real raw alright
reach in there you're gonna do the count
from Sesame Street I just I literally
just saw this on Wikipedia you appeared
in Sports Illustrated for women yeah if
you see his family like the entire
family's attracted yeah nieces are
beautiful I give you if you looked up
like Atlanta magazine right Griff and
his family what was the other one you
probably saw in there too he was rocking
bad boy clothing he was awesome but
actually am you know they use a model
fluffy now yeah and UFC now they kind of
switched hands a few times gotcha he was
in a remake of Shirley Murdock's as we
lay oh yeah what's going on Kelly Price
did it yeah alright so that was fun
Reed this has the the count oh the
counts like the one how many times it's
kind of hard to do that how many
elements that's on the periodic table
can you name in one minutes okay we're
gonna all do this together we all did
this in chemistry we were like junior
high we've never had to think about it
again how many elements from the
periodic table can we name I'm gonna
time it Wow
ready set go oxygen helium helium
hydrogen in there zinc zinc zinc
magnesium copper copper silver yep goes
in there you're
uranium yeah titanium magnesium yep
pretty sure we say that lashbrooke pick
your [ __ ] mouth
what there's another one in there
hydrogen oxygen carbon carbon stop
repeating things while you brought
repeating like classic nitrogen nitrogen
good one why do we even have the
periodic because it's the elements that
make up the universe nobody nobody
everyone more way to get one more is
boron on there
nailed it boron yes boron Oh Hans one
thing you should always remember because
it was so fun because you look at your
friend be like you're a boron yeah
you were the poorer that segment god
what voice should he do Grif does the
last do the what voice unless you have a
good one that a fan submitted that you
should do you know that fan that
submitted these is our good friend woody
yeah she's great she's off yes great but
I'll listen do you do Arnold
Schwartzenegger again
oh man come on the best part about
saying do Schwarzenegger is that other
people do it because you could run on a
football field during the game that you
wouldn't actually be afraid of what's
the smallest animal where you would be
afraid of what this thing said that she
wouldn't be afraid of with the largest
animal that you wouldn't be so this is
great cuz of Monday Night Football yes
for the cat ran on the field you see
nobody went after that cat not touching
that nobody even bothered
leash could've never gotten sliced up
like I have if it was a man running a
little field everyone was trying to
attack him what yeah a little caddy like
nope no Denis would take a step towards
well they knew they were gonna get they
knew they were gonna get shook up - oh
yeah you imagine if you get crossed I'm
like oh man I was getting crossed out
you're going on every highlight reel
you're getting crossed up
yeah so the question is what is the
biggest animal that would surprisingly
go in a field that you would not be
afraid of and what's the smallest animal
that you would be afraid of I'll start
if there was a scorpion on the field I'm
not gonna be the one to get corporate on
a few yeah how do you feel about
scorpions now you throw scorpion I like
scorpions yeah it's an insect with an
exoskeleton chula something like that
[Music]
kills the spiders in your house me I
have no choice
my wife is definitely afraid and my son
is too he's that when I kill a spider I
want credit
like when I kill a spider I walk I want
my fiance to be like I appreciate you
and she's like I know you're not even
squishing vacuum what you got sucked a
vacuum oh it's great you gotta fly but I
kill it I always do it for way too long
some spiders are tricky they can get
flat so you try to kill I would not be
an innate of a cow I know Griff has to
leave soon I would not be afraid of a
cow walked on the field I would job I
would tip the cow yeah yeah I like that
cow big animal good cow might be the one
that was good stuff guys what's the
smallest animal we said do you say he
says accordion
let's go PA well I think spider might be
the answer for all three of us I don't
think any of us for spiders spiders will
snake some like that yeah I'm not
touching snakes either that's end on
that what are what are your what are
your irrational fears that really scare
the crap any spiders is up there for me
is it it is i I've never been in
situation where I've been like terrified
but it's also in a few times right yeah
okay
yeah yeah I'd say Spyder I think snakes
for me and I'm not like I'm not scared
to touch a snake but when they're around
and cuz you're like a horse farm
let them have it you ever see the video
of Eric Berry deathly afraid of horses
no tonight to all the listeners out
there to you to just type in Eric Berry
horse and watch him at a Broncos game
freaking out because they run that horse
on the field
Wow losing his [ __ ] deathly afraid he
had I had a world-class athlete on my
horse farm I'm gonna begged me to ride
horses with her and she's a World Cup
Olympic athlete I'm gonna tell your name
Simone biles I would not tell your name
joshie join her she's got on the horse
and started crying freaking out I can't
believe he's running he's robbed like
I'm literally standing here holding his
damn horse freaking out crying get me
off this thing going crazy jumped off
the horse
literally jumped off the horse I think
my fear is going to a restaurant curated
by Brian Westbrook yes it would be all
good food but it wouldn't be like those
plates with with the little separated
separated compartments because I don't
like stuff touching each other either
see you like it Thanksgiving Oh No a
little bit this and then I'm gonna get a
new plate and then eat the other stuff
that I haven't eaten already think this
all comes from man I'm like hot stuff
together like co-star together I don't
like you know I don't like I don't like
nuts in cookies because soft stuff
doesn't belong with the heart you like
cookie this is not apple pie or vanilla
ice cream now that that works that works
good Americans trying to figure how you
would make a nice Thanksgiving Day plate
and not have the food touch it now you
get down I don't I don't want it to be
integrated I wanted to be generated to
be separate and that's probably less for
everybody it's just the rules China
peanut [ __ ] man I appreciate you guys
I say this one I mean this one I says we
did not even get into 190th of your
story from your work with the NFL and
how you've looked after players to all
of your post career stuff to like
your entire career I wanted this to be
fun but you have an open invitation to
come back whenever awesome and I respect
both of you guys because you I think
you're both examples of people that once
the careers over has found your other
lanes and I think that's it's pretty
beautiful because I think that there's
and this isn't just athletes and then
there's a lot of people that look at
their current situation they go I feel
stuck and I look at both of you guys and
I get you got like no I'm gonna figure
this [ __ ] out and I respect you how a
most definitely shape dammit look Griff
go make some money because I know that
you're gonna you're the [ __ ] man
brother thank you bro guys all right
shoulder pads back in the day - oh man
the biggest like out here oh you were
the opposite of Michael Bennett Michael
Bennett had those Tyler pads on so you
had the big ones
well everybody had on bigger pants back
in the day that's right more surface
more hidden
uh-huh that would Griff is the man and
then as we get done the interview by the
way thank you to Robert Griffith yeah he
really did like I saw him last night I
was like do you want to come on they're
like sure we were looking at stuff up
afterwards incredible dude what were
some of the stuff you found he's got so
many things I mean obviously he sent a
bunch of kids at school to college he
was a Minnesota man of the year he's an
NFL man of the NFL man of the year I
mean he did listen man anytime you give
back to communities like that drunk
rehab stuff like that to me that's
amazing
because that's giving back when you
don't have to he was rich had everything
ahead of him and he gave back of himself
then he did really didn't have to do
that I was that guy that when I was
watching the NFL he was always looking
like the wise vet uh-huh like he was
always the dude that would have the
defense in the right order I didn't ask
him but I if I were to interview him
again I would want to about just Darren
Sharper just all the [ __ ] that happened
there and being like did you ever think
that that would happen just because I'm
still surprised about all that disgust
you know what's weird
um so Darren Sharper went to William and
Mary and we used to they were in our
league and so we were kind of not that
we were great friends or closer because
the image sharper that was the Viking
say yes they were gay and they were very
very good and he's a man of the year and
Darren Sharper is spending like the rest
of his life in part-time
yeah it's just and you think like so I
just I wasn't gonna talk about that the
first night you didn't want to go no no
I wanna have a good time
there's no way you could the ones you
didn't see that coming
no one saw that coming though yeah of
course what is the good do right here
man I mean you taught my key back in
here and Westbrook was like did you know
all the stuff that he did like yeah he's
amazing guy sending biking challenge I
mean you doing a bunch of stuff but he
still is obviously he's a cyclist as
well I mean all over the place and then
the other thing that I saw when I walked
in here was Westbrook trying to learn
all the periodic tables yes so which
ones are the ones that you missed that
you're like oh there's a bunch of them
that I had no clue were even on the
period let's read Brian Westbrook
surprising periodic elements um number
one oh man you can't pronounce any of
these try try okay Actium ooh that's
great
number two aluminum obvious we know that
American America it's very prideful but
sometimes a little bit too focused on it
Simoni antimony there's no way you're
reading these correctly I have no we'll
try another one now the A's may be
calcium is in there yep californium ooh
yeah it's a little bit crunchy sometimes
doesn't give Harlem's in the air is a
chlorine chlorine chlorine chlorine
copper no those yeah
maybe a little bit like old helium
hydrogen got those down iron
there's about something that I just
didn't know LED LEDs on there did you
believe that yeah no I - nothing you got
you I bet you a nickel she's got that
one lettuce PB right lead is PB yeah how
did you know that you seem to be like a
nerdy type of guy in school were you
good grades and you tell me just because
I knew that letter was PBR gonna call me
a nerd did you get good grades in school
this is who I was I was you gotta kiss
give me explanation just answers I have
a solid b-plus student okay that did not
do a lot of studying yeah but I was able
to use context clues and my incredible
street skills
he's kids who do well on tests I think I
was a pretty good student I was a lot
better at math than I was in English
meets so the science is I was good at
you know what
was I was I was one of these kids dead
I'd always did my homework and all he's
paid attention in class I never studied
though which to me worked for me did you
have people take tests for you in
college excuse me I went to a
institution of higher learning no no and
you know helped you cheated these
Villanova University institution of
higher learning and you live in the area
so you know how good of a school is so
no we did I just know that you guys are
always top-ranked in certain categories
absolutely business school nursing
people what Villanova is always like top
five and most attractive people of
course what do you mean in the u.s.
which means that like they related to
step it up they didn't mean a lot of
people look good if I was they just went
online and the first thing I saw was
Bill Polian omits quote I was wrong
about Lamar Jackson I'd like to do a
follow up called time out people listen
to what Bill Polian had to say Bill
Polian why are you asking why did you
ask who asked him that question
well no Bill Polian had a thing when
Lamar was coming out that he thought he
should have been more of a wide receiver
of course there are not often times
where people have takes that are
remembered as being so bad that that
defines their like take career like
there was a time for Colin Cowherd where
his John Wall takes yes he could not get
away from it
Bill Polian is in the Hall of Fame he's
one of the greatest football executives
of all time but for the rest of my life
I will know him as the guy that said
Lamar Jackson so play wide receiver
because he's black there's a lot of guys
that said that because he's black but
Bill Polian was the guy he went on he
was the face of the moon uranium did we
say that one yeah
10 I'm just saying there's this one
[ __ ] you we should we should we
should do more of this because I'll tell
you right now there's a bunch of these
95% of these no one can pronounce I
guarantee that no one can it's not
they're not even English words these are
just words that letters that are put
together that don't even make sense
these are the periodic thing goes down
periodic table yes ma'am I literally
just said that some people have takes
that will define when I think we may
have just found yours Brian Westbrook
quotation mark the periodic table is
dumb
quote-unquote I'll guarantee you this
there here's it let me ask you this all
right this is gonna go out to the 33
first here's it here's a question how
much how many times have you even
thought about the periodic table as an
adult I think when someone goes that's
some high-quality h2o I go kiss that's
two hydrogen's that one ox you'd never
think of it nobody ever uses it you
learned it in the seventh grade and you
never use it again
that means it's useless so I love that
that's like a very popular take which is
like while you teach me how to pay my
mortgage explained division no but ya
know this is pointless this is a great
example of something that unless you're
gonna be a scientist little kids don't
bother to learn it cuz your integration
what are you gonna do when your kids
come to you and they say I need to learn
the periodic my son don't waste your
time you got bigger things bigger fish
to fry
don't waste your time exactly he's gonna
be working at McDonald's Phil get your
foot [ __ ] like I told you get your golf
club or your baseball son Chargers
Raiders make a Peck Thursday Night
Football charges Raiders charges had a
big win this past week I'm generator so
do the Raiders or Raiders I like Raiders
what's really interesting is whoever
wins this team is secretly in the NFL to
the playoff picture yes
and whoever loses is secretly so like
the Chargers are four and five the
Raiders are four and for Raiders their
first home game win a shootout with the
Lions Chargers everyone's going oh maybe
we shouldn't have slept on him there
four and five so the Chargers wouldn't
they go to five and five then the AFC
they're in it Raiders they win they're
five and four well think about this the
Chargers they got their pass rows back
so Ingram as well as both so they look
explosive this past week there's gonna
be a secret lair Thursday Night Football
Keenan Islands healthy Mike wings as
healthy and Melvin Gordon came back till
I know so offensively and defensively
they look much better and I thought
coming into the season they would be
much better than they are early on in
the season a struggle you go you went
chargers
I went Raiders but now that I'm thinking
about it I certainly can see why I would
choose charges as well I'll bet you a
money that the Raiders would you taking
a boozer game at in Oakland I'll take
that you'll take the Chargers yeah take
turns our money our money thank you yes
I'll take that at this point you owe me
like three money's at this point I
you're gonna come in on Monday with your
little phone and your little recordings
and there's
we make them crap evidence yes now I
respect your your past your [ __ ]
periodic table love you guys a lot if
you root for the Chargers it means
you're rooting for Westbrook
if you root for the Raiders that means
you're rooting for me go to pick us up
bolts for Westbrook the Rocket Man I am
the lef koe man you waiting put to beat
the drop I like that man
shoutout to Robert Griffith let me just
see what his Twitter him he's a great
dude great dude he he is truly an old
head that actor I wouldn't send to his
face Griff 24/7 oh that's pretty good
that's his handle he's truly an all head
that I would want to advise me of my
life look if I had an issue I'd be like
Griff I got I got anything so calm -
like a look bro and the callee and any
waste your time finally some time it is
the caveum bigger pads bigger hips
peace out homies see you guys later